what's auditing so auditing is so we
described earlier dynetics auditing
Scientology auditing is uh very similar
to that so at first glance it it looks
like Psychotherapy a kind of therapy all
Scientology auditing is going to look
like that it's one-on-one talk therapy
uh you're in a room by yourselves no
distraction no noise one on one yeah so
like this yeah but and in Scientology
they have what's called an e-meter right
almost all auditing employs the use of
an emitter what's an e-meter so an
e-meter is a device that just measures
the resistance to a small electrical
flow except scientologists believe that
this emitter can be used to Simply
direct the progress of an auditing
session to determine whether uh
the auditing has reached a good
satisfactory
conclusion
all auditing sessions have to end on a
satisfactory conclusion like that's the
job of the auditor there's you don't
just it's not like sorry the session
sucks see you next week it's not like
that every auditing session has to end
um on a positive note and if it doesn't
uh there's corrections to be made so
um the e-meter what does it look like
visually like oh you can pull it up
pull up Mark 8 emitter Mark 8. so
there's a few dials yeah there's a basic
information about time and duration I'm
presuming that a dial that just goes
zero to something okay so let's say that
the meter's in front of me and you're
the one holding the cans I'm holding the
cancel your enter you're doing the
auditing of me yeah okay okay I'm
holding the cans no literally in the
beginning of an auditing session when
you're calibrating the sensitivity
sensitivity of the emitter you do like a
can squeeze so I squeeze the cans please
okay so I'm just like squeezing yeah and
I'm just changing the sensitivity
because when you squeeze the cans I want
to get about a one-third of a dial drop
on the needle the idea is you don't want
if the needle is too sensitive then
every time you shift around in your
chair the needle is going to bounce all
over the place so you're trying to set
the sensitivity to this thing and that's
all the the knob there on the bottom to
the left that's the sensitivity knob and
that determines just uh how much how
sensitive the needle is going to be and
the the bigger dial is called the tone
arm and that is changing uh I want to
say voltage or current but I'm not
intending I'm going to get one of those
words that's wrong right but it is a
real device it's a real device so you
can actually calibrate uh to probably
you know get an outcome that you want
yeah so here's even how just how a
Scientology auditor believes it works
you're holding the cans there's a tiny
little battery in that emitter that's
sending you're completing the circuit
when you pick up the cans right so you
got a little thing go in there and that
needle will respond to your physical
movement but that's not what we want we
want you to sit the hell still so that
we can read this thing when I'm asking
you questions okay so you're sitting
there still very still as still as you
can comfortable right and I'm gonna go
is there something you're withholding
from me and what I'm looking for is
right when I say at the end of me I'm
looking for the needle to dip to the
right having a needle even if it's kind
of random
can really be like um a catalyst for a
conversation that's what it's used for
except it's an enforced conversation so
I'll give you a really good example of
this
so
you're holding the cans say is there
anything you're withholding from me
and I get an instant read
and I go is there anything you're
withholding from me you're gonna go I
don't think so and I don't see the
needle no you don't see the needle okay
I go well what did you think of when I
asked you the question now if you've
already had a lot of auditing you know
how this goes it means I got an instant
read and we're not going to move on
until this question gets resolved okay
so you're gonna go I don't know what I
was thinking of and then I'm gonna I'll
be like you know take a look and I'll
help you out here I'll try to steer you
okay so I'm looking to get roughly the
same read while you're thinking about
whatever I mean what was that what was
that right there and you can start
digging to what you can start I just
want an answer to the question okay and
I can go to memory yeah and you can give
me any answer you want there's no way
for me to know if you're giving me the
right answer but I want you to give me
something yeah if you say you can't give
me anything I'm going to keep using the
email until you give me something yeah
okay so let's say you give me something
I'm going to get all the details about
that and until like time place form an
event I want to know everything that
happened I want to know all the details
by the way I'm writing all this down so
I'm taking notes of everything you're
telling me that it's a bad thing that
you did that you haven't told me about
okay so I'm keeping notes when you
represent to me that you've told me
everything there is to tell I'm looking
for the needle
to give like a smooth back and forth
motion like this and Scientology calls
that a floating needle that means in
Scientology land we're done with that
so now I might go back to check the
question okay good I'll check the
question again is there anything you're
withholding from me oh if I get another
read we got to go through the process
again okay if you tell me I've told you
everything and I don't get a floating
needle I've got to go okay is there an
earlier similar
thing have you basically done an earlier
similar thing is there an earlier
similar time you haven't told someone
something or is there an earlier similar
thing that you did the thing that you
just told me
we're going to keep going earlier
similar earlier similar earlier similar
until I get a floating needle and that's
where I'm explaining it this way you can
see how no matter what the specific
auditing session happens to be about
there's still the potential in any
auditing session that you're going into
past lives yeah just because you have to
go earlier similar until you get a
floating needle okay now here's how
scientologists think the emitter
actually works meaning why does the
emitter work so we talked before about
these um these mental pictures right
these recordings okay well we spoke
about engrams just recordings of pain
and unconsciousness
well Scientology would hold the the bad
recordings aren't the only recordings
that you have those are just the
recordings in your reactive mind you
also have an analytical mind which is
just your conscious memory conscious
recording of everything from present
time to the last 76 trillion years yeah
and Hubbard would say that these
memories are actually a perfectly
detailed recording and he says like 56
perceptions or something and that it's
perfect
and you can access that information you
just have trouble doing so okay so he
says that these recordings these mental
pictures have actual electrical charge
and Mass
now you asked before is there any actual
physics in this I don't know where are
you supposed to store the pictures of
your last 76 trillion years that have
charge in Mass
I don't see it but Hubbard says it's
there okay
so he says that these things have mass
and when you recall them or put
attention on them
you create an electrical flow
which maybe through magnetic fields or
whatever impinges upon the electrical
flow of the emitter and it shows up as a
read on the needle that's how
Scientology that's how scientologists
believe that's why the needle reads now
cynics would say the needle only reads
on Palm sweat and movement well I know
that's not true
right I can't tell you everything the
needle does read on but I can tell you
it's not just moving your hands in
sweaty hands it does correlate to
thoughts probably some way somehow
because if it didn't correlate to
thoughts that this process would be way
way too inefficient because it would it
would be 200 they're they're good
there's going to be a bunch of people
who are just not you're not going to get
the what is it called the floating
needle like no matter what I can't
explain to you how you get a floating
needle but it sure as hell isn't hand
sweat and it sure as hell isn't
squeezing the cans right so you
eventually most people will get to the
floating needle and some you get
floating needles there's like a feed
there probably is a feedback mechanism
that you will each person realizes how
their mind and body yeah because you
want a resolution right it's probably
you want your needle to float for both
people yes and it's probably a great
experience when you're like yes it's
like a gamified feeling right well when
you're training on how to use the
e-meter there are drills where you
practice generating with your mind
various needle reactions so you know
there is a drill where you sit there and
you consciously try to create a floating
needle by recalling happy thoughts go to
your happy place
and at the end of every auditing session
you actually have to go to an a third
party sit down in front of an email and
verify that your needle is floating nice
every single auditing session not only
has to end on the floating needle but
then you have to go to someone else and
have the floating needle verified any
Scientologist who's uh a seasoned
recipient of auditing knows how to make
their needle float at The Examiner
got to be honest though this process
again sorry to be sort of going there
but
um
it feels like this is a very uh rigorous
talk therapy session is there good
aspects to this sure a lot of people
find auditing very helpful I mean I've
heard some describe it as quite
thoroughly addictive me personally I
never enjoyed getting auditing that's
probably more a function of having been
raised in it and it was never something
I wanted to do something was forced on
me as a child you know and also I was
never I don't like talking about private
secret stuff like you kind of you kind
of have to want to be an open book sure
to to honestly and thoroughly
participate in an auditing session
because there's not necessarily A belief
that this is going to be private there's
no expectation of privacy but there's no
expectation that your stuff's going to
be leaked for blackmail either I mean
you kind of you trust the people in the
organization
even despite rumors and stuff like that
but the rumors are coming from people
that are lying to you essentially
if you're a Scientologist and you're
participating in participating in an
auditing session you know that anyone in
the organization is has the ability to
know the stuff that you talk it's not
like oh my God I'm only telling my
auditor because I think no one's ever
gonna know you know that people know but
you also trust the organization how
quickly does it go to past memories for
people who are seasoned like they
actually like going past life yeah I I
hated it I would make sure I was really
good at making my needle float I didn't
want to have some auditor because I
never believed in the past life memories
yeah so I didn't want to be in that
impassable you know reach an impasse in
an auditing session where I was being
asked for something I couldn't provide
because I knew this auditing session has
to end on a good point but
scientologists enjoy for the most part
going they call it whole track whole
track is past life going whole track
your time track they call it the time
track is your whole memory but whole
track refers to anything past life okay
so going whole track or deep hole track
with high reality meaning it's not like
oh I have a fuzzy memory and I'm not
sure if it's real like your real season
scientologists are like oh yeah I was on
this planet this time circling this one
before that I was eating for breakfast
fascinating before the origin of life on
Earth so so billions of years ago on a
distant planet where you were eating for
breakfast or other universes I wonder if
there's a nice shortcut
to sneak up to actual trauma that
happened to you as a therapy device I
just so putting Scientology aside I just
I'm thinking about as a technique for
therapy discussing basically you know
some people have trauma and one of the
things you do with therapy is like bring
the trauma to the surface that's the
stuff that happened to your childhood
maybe it's a more convenient thing to do
to kind of map that indirectly onto a
fictitious telling of what happened to
you
something like that trauma on a distant
planet elsewhere it could be it could be
a nice way to sneak up to it yeah and it
goes both flows there not just things
that have happened to you but things
that you've done so you know you could
be being asked for you know you'd be
going back to I wiped out a civilization
committed Genesis I don't know this race
on this planet oh wow oh yeah
but so you can actually take on a whole
new guilt oh yeah so I I okay all right
you might actually take on a lot more
guilt and let go of because if you feel
like that self-critical aspect of the
brain
boy because I'm my brain is really
self-critical so I could see myself
manufacturing if I was forced to over
time some kind of story where I did
genocide a whole population of like
Pluto or something at a different
distant is somewhere in Alpha Centauri
yeah so I mean and now I walk around
with that guilt wait am I actually a
horrible person so imagine though if you
had not only are you looking at you know
if someone's being self-critical trying
to identify destructive patterns of
behavior in your present life but what
if you really internalize the fact that
I haven't only been this way
for 40 years I've been this way for 40
trillion years yeah
but Scientology would argue
that as a thetan you're inherently good
all things are basically good so the the
goal of the auditing procedure there
would be essentially to figure out find
the moment find what it was that caused
you
to make that shift as a being
to dramatize you know evil intentions
and stuff like that so even if you're
going whole track
looking at all the horrible things
you've done the goal is to find like
well what happened just prior to that
what was like the prior confusion and
what what did you misunderstand just
before that and whatnot so the goal is
basically so scientologists after a lot
of auditing are also convinced that they
have fixed the reason
for any non-optimum
conduct and underlying this is a belief
that at the core we're all good yes
there's a lot of really powerful ideas
in Scientology which is so interesting
that it goes wrong yeah okay uh what
about the training you mentioned the
training of the auditor that's really
interesting so what's how lengthy is
that process it can take years
I mean one of that question I want to
ask is are people in Sea org like as an
auditor do you believe everything how
much
um is there a crisis of faith that
Creeps in religion you have a crisis of
faith when you start to wonder like does
God even exist so in this case how often
do you start to doubt
that some of the core beliefs of
Scientology are false
Scientology would say that Scientology
is not about beliefs it's about a
application of the techniques of
Scientology auditing to improve
someone's spiritual awareness and
ability so the belief level of
Scientology is pretty much the stuff
we've already discussed the
effectiveness of the auditing process so
the effectiveness of the auditing
process is one of the things Hubbard
says is that standard Tech standard
Scientology they call it the tech the
technology of how to deliver auditing
standard Tech Works 100 of the time when
applied 100 correctly well that's kind
of unfalsifiable right yeah because
anytime it doesn't work it wasn't
applied correctly exactly
that's a nice little uh escape hatch to
pull on having a crisis of faith but it
didn't work well
then obviously it wasn't applied
correctly that's where quality control
comes in their job is to nitpick and you
can always find one thing that wasn't
done correctly communism
uh didn't work because it wasn't
implemented correctly it's the it's
always it's always it's always an escape
hatch with ideologies that's right sure
that's right I would probably argue that
Auditors
um are not in a position of having many
crisis of Faith because actually they're
usually seeing people for the most part
improve in some ways through the process
of auditing now auditing can create like
a state somewhat of a euphoric State you
feel great you're just blown out of your
head you know you feel fear on top of
the world I've had that in some of my
auditing
as an auditor sorry no as a person
receiving auditing okay and so my point
is as an auditor doing a lot of auditing
you know you're going to have someone in
front of you called the the pre-clear is
the person in front of you who's getting
the auditing called the PC or the
pre-clear
they see over and over and over again
these PCS having these sort of euphoric
States and floating needles and I feel
great and fantastic oh thanks you saved
my life like
I've always said if Scientology if
people didn't find Scientology helpful
nobody would ever stay in Scientology
and so Auditors are pretty much the ones
doing the heavy lifting of what it even
means to be a Scientologist those guys
aren't the ones that you end up
um having crisis of faith I mean doing
Scientology auditing it doesn't require
that you believe just have faith that
you believe something you just have to
go through these motions and
scientologists one of the reasons
scientologists think this is all
scientific is because it's like I don't
care if you believe why this works I
care how you feel at the end of an
auditing session and empirically
speaking
like anecdotal data is it actually seems
to improve people's lives within the
context so taking the outside world out
of it within this particular
organization
you're actually measurably seeing
Improvement yes is that is that some
degree real because like if you look at
a book like Animal Farm
where the pigs start to rule the other
animals and over time the life of the
animals gets worse and worse and worse
while the pigs keep saying that's
actually getting better and better and
better again communism same thing the
the rationing is getting worse and worse
and worse less and less food but there's
constant reporting uh that there's more
and more food where we're winning
hashtag I would argue that what you've
just described it could be
an identical description of what it
feels like and what it means to go up
scientology's bridge to total freedom
you are reinforcing to yourself that
everything's getting better and better
and better and and you'd be like
you don't spend time with your family
anymore yeah you're broke even though
you make a lot of money you're always
stressed you're you're at the beck and
call of these people who seem to run
your run your lives like how a
Scientologist feels about their own life
is
um it's very interesting to compare that
to how that person's life looks to their
non-scientology family members I get
contacted by a lot of people who've
never been in Scientology but like I got
a family member who's who's really deep
and I just can you help me understand
some things why is this person's life
like this why is this person's life like
this
so I I don't want to say that
scientologists do not actually I don't
want to say oh it's all in their heads
they think they're being held but
they're really not that doesn't feel
honest you know but it's this thing
where if Scientology was just
getting auditing
when you wanted
about the subjects you wanted and you
could take it or leave it that would be
fine
it's it's the fact that it's part and
parcel to this entire organization and
this entire experience
that has as a part of that experience
taking everything from you demanding
everything from you controlling who you
can speak with controlling who you can
have relationships with who you have to
erase from your life this is where and
it's hard to it's hard to place one
pinpoint on this is where Scientology
goes wrong it's really hard to do that
because the good parts of Scientology
and the bad parts of Scientology
are all just Scientology yeah so there's
definition of what's bad for you and
it's probably in the beginning is bad
for you
um this almost just sounds like a
template of a toxic relationship you
know there's a bunch of stuff in this
world that are just not good for you so
the uh the authority the authoritarian
says like I'm just protecting you by
blocking you off from those negative
things and they're probably they are
probably negative things but then this
like uh this Freedom starts closing in
to where you can't no longer speak
freely think freely act freely and
there's some I mean that's why sort of
power corrupts and absolute power
corrupts absolutely that person doing
the controlling actually starts getting
that like dopamine Rush of the
controller that's exciting and it's a
vicious negative cycle so you start out
as it it starts out good because you're
trying to do good for the person
um but then it somehow goes to [__]